me too and time's up
have highlighted that harassment and
discrimination are a shockingly common
part of many people's lived reality and
that this reality extends into the
workplace whether in tech or finance
sports or the service industry every day
we seem to hear another story about an
abuse of power or another grossly
inappropriate workplace behavior people
are furious they're taking to Twitter
and social media to voice that this must
change but it's time to move beyond the
hashtag it's time for us to report
harassment and discrimination to those
who can fix this mess and it's time for
us to talk about harassment in a more
inclusive way not just about sexual
harassment but to encourage people to
come forward about harassment and
discrimination based on other
characteristics such as age disability
or ethnicity because only together can
we fix the underlying causes and
consequences of harassment
you see most of us will at some point in
our lives experience workplace
harassment or discrimination
research shows that particularly women
people of color and people who openly
identify as LGBTQ I are likely to be
targeted and for some people this is a
pervasive and persistent part of the
reality and for most of these people
ninety-eight percent according to some
studies most of these people will never
speak up and tell their employer too
often harassment discrimination is a
lonely and isolating experience but we
need to help people out from under their
desks we need to empower people to have
a voice the reasonable first question
that everybody asks once they've been
harassed is what do I do now and this is
what I want to help you with navigating
the barriers to reporting can be
absolutely dizzying how can we speak up
in a society that too often discredits
or diminishes our experiences how can we
speak up in a society that is likely to
be retributive towards us
how can we deal with the silencing that
goes on all around us making matters
worse often our memories are the only
evidence we have of what happened now
here's where I can come in I'm a memory
scientist and I specialize in how we
remember important emotional events I
have particularly focused on how the
memory interview process can severely
impact the evidentiary quality of
reports that we produce a bad interview
can lead you to forget details or miss
remember them well a good interview can
forever change your life for the better
after looking at lab reports and working
studying this issue both in the
courtroom and in research settings I've
dissected all the different things that
can go wrong with our memories that can
really threaten your case and now I'm
turning my attention to helping people
tackle recording and reporting of
workplace harassment and discrimination
there's three things that I've learned
from my research on this that you can
immediately apply if you've been
harassed or discriminated against at
work I want to help you turn your memory
into evidence
evidence that even a memory skeptic like
me is unlikely to find fault with first
of all James Comey had it right the
former head of the FBI used to sit in
his car lock himself in after meetings
with the presidents and write down
absolutely everything he could remember
about what happened then now famous
recordings proved to be quite useful
later on be like Comey now you don't
need to lock yourself into your car to
do this but please immediately after
something happens I want you to
contemporaneously record what happened
and do this before talking to anyone
else about it because as soon as you
share your story with friends or family
or colleagues or therapists you have the
potential to distort or change your
memory of the event uncontaminated
contemporaneous evidence is worth gold
second the type of evidence matters sure
you can do a handwritten note of what
happens but how do you prove when you
wrote it instead pull out your computer
or smartphone and may
and knit a note that's time stamps where
you can prove this was recorded at this
time
contemporaneous time stamp evidence is
better finally make sure what you're
writing down is actually relevant too
often we see that people bring out
facebook messages they bring out time
stamp pieces of evidence but sure
they're not particularly relevant
they're not particularly useful it's
easy to write an emotional unstructured
account of what happens understandable
because it's an emotional experience but
those might not actually be the details
that matter later on for an
investigation write down this list I
want you to keep track of this and
simply fill in the blanks first of all
what happens in as much detail as
possible describe the situation and do
it on the day it happened if at all
possible second who was there were there
any witnesses
this becomes crucial potentially later
on what exact time and date did this
happen
what location where did this happen who
did you tell after the event how did it
make you feel during and after it
happened and is there any other evidence
such as whatsapp's photos or emails that
might lend more credibility to your case
these are all details that are
incredibly easy to record
contemporaneously but are also
incredibly easy to forget later on
humans according to research often
overestimate their ability to remember
important emotional details later on
assume that you're going to forget
assume you have to write it down now
these three pieces of advice are a good
start but of course they don't overcome
a lot of the other barriers to reporting
according to the Equality and Human
Rights Commission which published a
report in 2018 there's one key
recommendation to overcome some of the
other fears often associated with
reporting these kinds of incidents to
your employer the one piece of advice
that they made have an online anonymous
reporting tool only that way they say
can you truly overcome many of the fears
associated with reporting now in line
was this and informed by what was
happening
all around me and taking and applying
the memory science the science that I'd
been doing for many years I sat down
with a number of people and we together
created talk to spot calm spot is an
online anonymous reporting tool that
helps you record and report workplace
harassment and discrimination it allows
you to do it anonymously it allows you
to do it for free and it's completely
evidence-based you don't have to talk to
a person there's no fear of judgments
and you can do it whenever and wherever
you need now you have the power to walk
through an evidence-based memory
interview now this is called a cognitive
interview this is the same technique
that police use when they're doing their
job properly so best-case scenarios
people who are being asked about
important emotional events are being
asked in line with the cognitive
interview now this walks you through all
the relevant information so that at the
end after you've talked to the bots
which is an automatic messaging system
after you've talked to the bots it
generates a PDF record that's
time-stamped and securely signed that
you can keep for yourself as evidence in
case you want to share it later or you
can submit it to your employer right
away and in line with recommendations
you can submit it to your employer
anonymously but a reporting tools only
as useful as the audience that's
listening so if your employer is truly
committed to change
we've decided to also offer them the
tool to respond so if organizations work
with us and are truly committed to doing
something about workplace harassment and
discrimination they're also able to
respond to you even if you've chosen to
stay anonymously we think it's important
that you can work together with your
employer to tackle this issue we think
that everybody wins when we bring light
into this dark issue whether it happens
to you or to someone you know recording
and reporting what happens can really
improve how we talk about these issues
and if you're an organization this is a
call to give your employees access to
better and more effective reporting
mechanisms we know that the
methods that are used in most argument
most organizations don't work
effectively it's time to change that if
you're committed to inclusion and
diversity it's time for us to celebrate
our diversity it's time for us to give a
voice to those who have for too long
been denied one it's time for us to
celebrate those who come forward even if
they feel they need to stay anonymous to
stay mass to do so it's time for a
reporting revolution thank you
[Applause]
[Music]